but now but rebel you do go to war it
was the was it an award show where you
were sat next to Kelly Osbourne
misbehaviour oh that was um Jennifer
Lopez's opening night in Las Vegas
couple weekend about don't you yeah yeah
I mean I still haven't found love so I
try to get out there you know you know
Kelly were kind of looking for love yeah
and then we notice Justin Bieber was
sitting two rows behind us and we
thought you know what Valentine's Day is
coming up we're both single let's just
make a play for him like a first we
thought it would be funny but then it
actually worked and we sent Justin a
note through our bodyguard I think we've
got the note alright so dear Justin my
name is Kelly Osbourne and my name is
Robert Wilson we think you should take
our sexy hot asses out after oh nothing
weird yeah you can see from exhibit a it
is ticked seven times
yes so I believe that means like seven
dates he owes me and you know I'm
thinking horse riding or a private pool
party he hasn't like got back in touch
with me about the actual day and I
should probably stop talking about it
cuz you're gonna think I'm like really
weird but you didn't get a picture taken
with you yeah yeah we hung out or not oh
do you yeah cuz I think most girls meet
Justin and be like ahh and be a bit
pathetic but like I mean even just was
like hey what's up
the game yeah I was a partner it looks
quite nervous you know no that's just
because I was holding his balls
so the idea was to dyeing my hair blonde
up but he just went ginger anything
wrong with that of course boyfriend was
a killer and he also slept with my my
half-sister slash cousin because it was
dark and he couldn't tell his heart